as we make way for the two-time World
Series champ Kirk Gibson Gibby how are
you hey good morning everybody's great I
was I want to mention the full thing
full intro here you're on a mission to
establish collaborative research amongst
top medical research organizations
finding a cure for Parkinson's disease
and for more information
Kirk Gibson foundation.org and during
the month of October all donors will be
entered in for a drawing for a chance to
win a sign Kirk Gibson MVP Baseball
commemorating the 30th anniversary of
the historic 1988 World Series home run
donate to help the cause at Kirk Gibson
foundation.org what do we not know about
that night gimme against akin 1988 I
think you know pretty much all we've
examined it a thousand different ways
you know as I watch the games going on
now it's great it's a great time to be a
you know in the playoffs a baseball
player you see some guys that aren't
they're struggling a little bit you see
some guys that are dominating a little
bit you're in a seven game series
I think the thing about it is who's
going to be the guy who's going to be
the guy that's going to overcome those
inner feelings that they're confused
they're lost or trying to find their
swing they're trying to find the right
release point on that slider it's just
that's what I love about the games what
I loved about playing the game I was
very fortunate to have been that guy a
couple times really in my career
yesterday on October 14th I hit the home
run off goose Gossage in 84 and today
the anniversary of the Dennis Eckersley
homerun and is you know just the
teammates and the people your support
groups around you how important they are
to keep you going
it'll all play out here in the next
couple of weeks to see you because world
champions you know I hit the homerun
but let's not discount with my teammates
did after I hit the homerun you know
they say it you mean you say me not
dennis eckersley I think hung up on
giving there I think that's what
happened there he's being humble too but
you know I want to ask him about that
that he wasn't even supposed to play and
told his wife to go home or Gibson back
with us I was reading some stuff on this
Gibby that Orel Hershiser was telling
Scioscia that you were going to
pinch-hit and you were trying to
underneath the tunnel or you were trying
to take some swings in the cage is that
how that played out yeah I was taking
swings out of the case
Earl knew because he was there
rubbernecking and it was in the game
actually he made one of the one of the
outs in the ninth inning so but then he
also told me not to embarrass myself so
ok you got to count to three two and
then you knew what was coming
why am L de da one of our advance scouts
had told the whole team and me
personally if we got the 3-2 count that
Dennis Eckersley would throw a 3-2
backdoor slider to a left-handed hitter
and be honest with you I mean I couldn't
handle the fastball you know I was not
feeling too good in my lower half so I
stepped out if you watch the tape and
the three to Dennis
became set I stepped on said partner
sure as I'm standing here breathing
you're gonna see a 3-2 backdoor slider
epic melodyday's words to me he threw it
and you know the ball went out amazingly
enough how did you get enough of the bat
on the ball though it's hard to explain
I think if you looked at the swing it
was just a combination of luck and just
snapping my wrist at the right time and
you know I knew it was drawn really
quickly and then the cool thing about
that was you know after the home run
went out we won the game my teammates
you know won the other games and we want
became world champions it's just an
amazing thing that happens who is faster
that night you or Tommy Lasorda
well I'm still faster if I had to jump
higher did you save anything from that
game are you a collector
I saved the jersey the bat
I've got virtually everything that I had
that games a t-shirt underneath that's a
Michigan big-game hunters t-shirt it was
a blue shirt have our batting home saved
it all the other thing I don't have I
don't think anybody's ever found is the
ball and I don't know that that will
ever be found I did not know that that
nobody came forward and said hey I'll
give you this ball if you give me a
signed jersey or something
nobody you never heard from anyone I did
get a picture from a young lady who
shouldered the ball hitter and the thigh
it was well bruised but I don't know who
got the ball at that time it wasn't
really big to say things as it is today
and I know that you guys got together
you and Dennis Eckersley got together
for a Joe Torre charitable cause was
that the first time you had ever
discussed that that moment with Dennis
Eckersley in person actually he went on
to become a hall-of-famer so a great
character he's actually very humorous
about it out we struck up quite a good
friendship and it's actually funded you
know be able to talk about it like that
he was a great competitor he respected
me and I respected him and we respected
the Oakland A's as well unfortunately if
it's just one of the small pieces that
helped us win that world championship
but you have that moment but that was
your only moment in 1988 you also won
the World Series for the Tigers so what
do you look back on with fonder memories
just what it takes how much you know I
believe in being a good teammate and
calling for each other and doing what it
takes to stay with each other
you know people you get down you get
excited and you have to regulate each
other you have to please police yourself
and everybody says that but it's all
about the buy in and we were able to buy
in an 88 we're able to buy in an 84 and
we had great leaders in Sparky Anderson
and Tommy Lasorda and our organizations
behind us the fans you know these guys
out there now they're having fun and
there's a lot that's going to go on in
everybody's head and there's going to be
some ups and there's going to be some
downs but ultimately need a little bit
of luck a lot of perseverance a lot of
determination will determine who the
next World Series champion is and that's
just fun when you have a parade after
you win a World Championship
there's nothing funner that I've ever
done in my life he's Kirk Gibson
two-time World Series champ trying to
draw attention a cure for Parkinson's
disease and you can donate help the
cause at Kirk Gibson foundation org how
is your health now Givi I'm good I got
diagnosed in 2015 it's something that I
was not aware of great help from many
people I've become aware of what my
disease is I understand how to deal with
it and I'm promoting others to become
aware and how they can deal with it as
well it's you know it's you know I had
to learn how to hit a screwball I'm ever
Mike Norris way back in the early 80s
through a screwball I couldn't hit it I
had to learn how to hit it in
Parkinson's a little tougher than a
screwball did you you played baseball
with it felt like a football mentality I
know you played football a little bit at
Michigan State did you ever wonder what
could have been if you had stuck with
football of course I do know that I
probably wouldn't have lasted long
because I really enjoyed contact so much
in football I remember when I got out of
football was playing
well initially I see guys run out of
bottles I said man go for that extra
five yards and I couldn't really
understand it but you know years later
involved makes sense you know I was kind
of like running over guy or outrun him
guy that wasn't the smartest way to go
about I think I would have done behind
but if I didn't smarten up I don't think
out of plate
I played 17 years in the big leagues and
in baseball won two World Championships
I don't think I could ever second-guess
my my choice although I did enjoy
football more than I hit baseball just
by mentality wise what do you remember
about the game Michigan State played
against Notre Dame you started that game
right I mean we played them for years in
your freshman yeah your first yeah yeah
we beat him down there and and by the
golden dome and I was my first game I
remember that our quarterback is Charlie
Baggett threw an interception and I got
I got aired out for it because they said
I ran the wrong pattern which that's I
guess we and and we watched the film's
the next day and it was apparent that I
didn't and our offensive coordinator
says well we'll just move on amongst
this play right here and I took Pete as
a rocky but you know a solid pond it's a
great learning experience we end up
winning that's all it counted and we had
you know three more years after that we
did not beat him and the toughest
defensive back I ever played against was
a guy named Luther Bradley you may
remember Luther Bradley and I was gone
to hear golf balls this year at 6 a.m.
at a golf range I saw a young black man
I said how are you doing young man and
he said I think I know you
I'm Luther Bradley Oh circle I said you
were pretty tough he said you weren't
bad yourself so you know I thought oh we
got his memories now you know your
teammates your leaders like I said it
all
come together to happen and you can do
everything right in any of these
competitions that doesn't work sometimes
but you know I just become determined
get after it the next year and hopefully
it'll happen for you Gibby good to talk
to you good luck in your pursuit a cure
for Parkinson's disease for more
information on that you can win a sign
Kirk Gibson MVP Baseball commemorating
the 30th anniversary of that historic
1988 World Series home run donate to
help the cause Kirk Gibson
foundation.org Thank You Gibby
thanks guys for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]